- Ready to drink the Kool-Aid.
- You know, growing up, my
mother wouldn't let me have it.
- It's sugar water.
- Awesome, to cavities, can't wait.
- [Voiceover] I love the
Elton John reference.
- In my childhood, I don't
remember the Kool-Aid guy
partying with so many awesome animals.
- This tastes like more just
like regular fruit punch.
- Yeah, I think it's
like, you guys hear that?
- It's got all these berries on it,
but we don't know which
berry it really tastes like.
- Um, was that good for
sound, it's good, all right.
- What was that?
- I'm excited about
this one, mainly because
it's named after, like, a dinosaur.
- It's like pink lemonade.
(hammering)
- There's no fruit in this at all.
- Hey, we're rolling sound in here.
What is that?
- I don't know.
- Excuse me, we're rolling sound.
(hammering)
- This is...
- OK, I think I'm picking
up something else.
(feedback) Ah, fuck.
- What happened?
- I don't know, I think it
picked up something else.
- But it is a strong Jolly Rancher smell.
- It's a tropical blast.
- This is like definitely
a summertime drink.
- Oh yeah.
- What is going on here guys?
- I don't know, I'm sorry
guys, this is ridiculous.
We're just gonna have
to do this another time
or something, I just, I can't...
(noise offscreen)
What the hell?
Oh...
- Hello?
Did you see that?
- Yeah.
- Hello.
- What are you doing?
- What was that?
Come on Ben, let's just go.
- Hello (screams)
- It's just so sad, what's
happening over there.
- Oh yeah, mmhmm.
Hm, you don't know the half of it.
(piano music)